sabiendo que iría a prisión por el resto de su vida
o lo que la vida le iba a deparar,
me inspiró y ha inspirado a otros periodistas
e inspirado, creo, a la gente en todo el mundo,
incluyendo los denunciantes futuros,
para darse cuenta de que pueden participar en ese tipo de comportamiento.
BG: Tengo curiosidad acerca de tu relación con Ed Snowden,
porque has hablado mucho con él,
y sin duda seguirás haciéndolo,
pero en tu libro, nunca lo llamas Edward,
ni Ed, usted dice "Snowden". ¿Cómo puede ser?
GG: Estoy seguro de que eso es algo
para que examine un equipo de psicólogos. (Risas)
Realmente no lo sé. La razón por la que creo que,
uno de los objetivos importantes que en realidad tenía,
uno de los suyos, en mi opinión, las tácticas más importantes,
era que él sabía que una de las formas
de distraer la atención de la sustancia de las revelaciones
sería tratar y personalizar el foco en él,
y por eso, se quedó fuera de los medios de comunicación.
Trató de no tener nunca su vida personal
sujeta a examen,
y así que creo que llamándolo Snowden
es una manera de solo identificarlo como este importante actor histórico
en lugar de tratar de personalizar
de manera que puedan distraer la atención de la sustancia.
Moderador: Entonces, sus revelaciones, su análisis,
el trabajo de otros periodistas,
realmente han desarrollado el debate,
y muchos gobiernos, por ejemplo, han reaccionado,
incluso en Brasil, con proyectos y programas
para reformular un poco el diseño de la Internet, etc.
Hay un montón de cosas que suceden en ese sentido.
Pero pregunto, a ti personalmente,
¿cuál es el final del juego?
¿En qué momento vas a pensar,
bueno, en realidad, hemos tenido éxito en mover el dial?
GG: Bueno, el final del juego para mí como periodista
es muy simple, es asegurarme
de que cada documento que es de interés periodístico
y que debe ser divulgado
termine siendo divulgado,
y que los secretos que nunca deberían haber sido
en primer lugar, terminen descubiertos.
Para mí, esa es la esencia del periodismo
y eso es lo que estoy comprometido a hacer.
Como alguien que encuentra la vigilancia masiva odiosa
por todas las razones que acabo de hablar y mucho más,
quiero decir, yo veo esto como un trabajo sin fin
hasta que los gobiernos de todo el mundo
ya no puedan someter a poblaciones enteras
a la supervisión y vigilancia
salvo que convenzan a alguna corte o alguna entidad
que la persona seguida
en realidad ha hecho algo mal.
Para mí, esa es la forma cómo la privacidad puede rejuvener.
BG: Entonces Snowden es muy, como hemos visto en TED,
es muy elocuente en la presentación y retratándose a sí mismo
como defensor de los valores democráticos
y los principios democráticos.
Pero entonces, a mucha gente realmente les resulta difícil creer
que esas son sus únicas motivaciones.
Les resulta difícil creer
que no había dinero de por medio,
que no vendió algunos de esos secretos,
incluso a China a a Rusia,
los que definitivamente no son los mejores amigos
de EE. UU. en este momento.
Y estoy seguro de que muchas personas en la sala
se plantean la misma pregunta.
¿Consideras posible que existe
una parte de Snowden que no hemos visto todavía?
GG: No, lo considero absurdo e idiota.
(Risas) Si quieres,
y yo sé que estás haciendo de abogado del diablo,
pero si quieres vender
secretos a otro país,
que él pudo haber hecho
y llegar a ser extremadamente rico al hacerlo,
la última cosa que haría es tomar esos secretos
y dárselos a los periodistas y pedirles que los publiquen,
porque eso los transforma en secretos sin valor.
Las personas que quieren enriquecerse
lo hacen en secreto con la venta de secretos para el gobierno,
pero hay un punto importante que merece mencionarse
y que la acusación viene
de la gente en el gobierno de EE. UU.
de la gente en los medios de comunicación leales
a estos diversos gobiernos,
y muchas veces cuando las personas acusan a otras —
"No puede realmente estar haciendo esto
por razones de principios,
debe tener alguna motivación corrupta, y nefasta" —
están diciendo mucho más sobre sí mismos
de lo que son el blanco de sus acusaciones,
porque — (Aplausos) —
esas personas, las que hacen esa acusación,
ellos mismos nunca actúan
por cualquier motivo que no sean razones corruptas,
entonces asumen
que todo el mundo sufre la misma enfermedad
de la falta de alma como ellos,
y por eso la suposición.
(Aplausos)
BG: Glenn, muchas gracias. GG: Muchas gracias.
BG: Glenn Greenwald.
(Aplausos)